remember more than more than a year ago
at this point almost two years I'm it
feels like 10 years ago when Donald
Trump gave carrier air-conditioning
company a bunch of money to keep a
factory in Indiana instead of moving
something like a thousand workers to
Mexico and then Trump claimed I did it I
heroically fixed and improved the
economy by giving money to this one
company and what I said at the time and
I know many of you were listening to the
show watching the show at the time and
you'll remember me saying this at the
time I said this isn't policy this isn't
a change in the economic and business
environment that led carrier to say I
think we should move these jobs to
Mexico because we're gonna be better off
financially by doing that when you go
and you give a handout to one company
and you get them to make the opposite
decision that the market would have
dictated you're not fixing the economy
at large you're not changing the economy
at large all you're doing is giving a
company money to stay it's effectively a
bribe and of course it failed hugely at
the time carrier almost immediately
admitted that actually over the long
term the money they got from Trump they
were gonna use to automate that Factory
anyway are those those uh job roles they
were going to ultimately move half of
those thousand jobs to Mexico anyway and
it was an absolute and total failure it
was a band-aid but it was like a crappy
old band-aid that barely had any
adhesive left to stick to your finger
and you can barely even really call it a
band-aid at this point an off-brand
band-aid it was just an adhesive bandage
it was an adhesive bandage that was not
even waterproof it was horrible whatever
analogy however far you want to go with
the analogy and now we have the exact
same thing but it's actually worse
because now Donald Trump is handing out
money to try to put a band-aid on a
problem that he created by choice the
problem of the trade war Trump's trade
war a war he can't win a war that was
optional is optional has crushed
American farmers crushed American
farmers I've been telling you about this
most of these farmers are in red states
and most of them at least mathematically
are Republicans they are Trump voters
and their Republican elected officials
are understandably upset about
what's going on so what Donald Trump has
now come up with to do is he's put
together a twelve million dollar I'm
sorry twelve billion dollar emergency
fund for the farmers and farmers are
going to start getting payments because
they're getting crushed because of
Trump's trade war does anybody
understand how stupid this is does
anybody care the so-called fiscal
conservatives how fiscally irresponsible
this is you start a trade war with the
idea that I guess in some long-term way
it's going to be good for the country
it's gonna be good for American
businesses it's gonna be good for
workers we know it's not going to be
good economists say you can't win this
there's evidence that it's not good
because we are already seeing American
farmers get completely and totally
crushed so instead of looking at undoing
the bad economic policy in the first
place Trump makes the decision to
compound the economic disaster by
spending twelve billion dollars of your
money on aid to farmers which will of
course much like giving money to carry
our air conditioner it's not going to
fix the problems that the trade war is
creating in the first place it's you
start with bad policy and then you put
bad policy on top of that what would
help farmers is fix the tariffs so that
they can get more access to foreign
markets instead of just giving them cash
and where are the fiscal conservatives
remember that when President Obama
bailed out the auto industry it was a
loan that was going to be repaid to
taxpayers with interest and at least the
portions that were loaned out under
Obama because remember some of it came
back from the Bush administration the
portions loaned out under Obama have
been paid back and Republicans still
went nuts saying you can't choose
winners and losers Obama didn't choose
winners and losers he gave out loans to
be paid back
this is actually choosing winners and
losers it's saying here are the farmers
that are losing because of the trade
policy and we're gonna throw cash at
them - at least on paper keep them as
winners disastrous embarrassing policy
yeah and while the bankers wanted a
bailout it doesn't appear like the
farmers want one themselves I don't know
I don't know that I'm
they're suffering and they've said some
of them have been interviewed and
they've said well we we know these
things can take a while but in the short
term they're getting crushed and I don't
see them turning the money away anyway
that's right but there are also some of
the hardest workers in the entire
country yeah they want to pull
themselves up by their bootstraps and
you know this is all the result of an
unforced error it's not like it's the
result of a famine or drought or
something and there's actually something
horribly brilliant about what Trump is
doing here as political strategy as
usual I have no idea if Trump is aware
of this if somebody that's working for
Trump is aware of this farmers should
punish Trump in November for ruining
their businesses and their livelihoods
they should not vote for the Republicans
that allowed Trump to do the trade war
and in 2020 they should definitely not
vote for Trump either Trump starts this
trade war and it crushes the farmers but
then he says listen I had to do it they
were ripping us off we were being
treated unfairly but here's some money
so that you'll be okay
and now those farmers need Trump because
it's much easier for whoever replaces
Trump or Democrats if they take over for
Republicans in the Senate in the house
to say we're not going to do the twelve
billion in payments anymore then it is
for Trump to change trade policy and now
the very people being crushed by Trump
are being held hostage to Trump's 12
billion dollars in payments because they
need the money and there's a particular
type of evil genius here and don't
forget that this was all caused by
Republicans the Republican president
starts the trade war the
republican-controlled House and Senate
allows it to happen
remember that Trump slammed Canada for
subsidizing their dairy industry which
made American dairy less competitive
what's Trump doing now by giving money
to farmers in the US it allows them to
charge less and end up with the same
amount of money because of the 12
billion in payments it is the same type
of subsidy that Trump slammed when it
was Canada doing it we are in total
idiocracy and i want to hear from you
about this I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show and boy do we have a good one for
you today I'm pleased to tell you that
today's show is underwritten by better
help.com slash Pakman therapy is in
horton we have a real crisis in our
country not just people who could
benefit from mental health services but
the stigma that surrounds mental health
services and as many people in the
audience know lots of people in my
family work in the field of mental
health and I have made it a mission of
the show to at any opportunity make
clear that there is absolutely no shame
whatsoever in going to talk to someone
when you feel that that's the right
thing to do and that's what better help
provides you get a fully licensed and
experienced psychologists and therapists
through videophone and text it's less
expensive than meeting in person with a
counselor after three months the price
goes down even more but you get the same
professional service that you would from
going into somebody's office and you
also get unlimited access you can speak
to a counselor every day if you want
signing up is easy you go to better help
calm slash Pakman fill out a
questionnaire they will pair you with a
therapist that works for you but you're
always able to switch to somebody else
if there's a better fit available go to
better help calm slash Pakman it's so
easy to sign up and get started we're
putting a link in the description if
you're watching this on YouTube it is
better help calm a /pa que ma n